If you're like me,
you assume the rest of the world
revolves around you,
but every now and then I'll pop my head
out of the sand to try to take stock of
what's going on outside of my world,
America and English speaking youtube,
and it's a good time to start paying
attention because some of the new
biggest channels in the world are
building their audiences totally outside
of Western countries,
which means you probably haven't heard
of them yet.
And the one we're going to pay attention
to today is t series from India.
T series is growing so fast they're set
to pass pewdie pie in subscriber numbers
in fewer than six months.
We're going to talk about why and how t
series got to the top.
Was it luck,
timing,
fortune.
We're going to talk all of that and
more,
but before we get into how t series shot
up the youtube ladder,
let's give it a little bit of
background.
T series is a bollywood music production
company started by gold,
Sean Kumar.
They originally sold bootleg bollywood
songs,
but after some smart moves,
explosive growth and their founder being
assassinated by the Mumbai underworld,
they emerged on top in the Bollywood
music scene,
especially on youtube where they're the
second largest channel in the world
right now,
but let's make that more tangible with
numbers.
PD Pie is set to grow by 9 million
subscribers this year.
In that same time period t series,
we'll get 38 million subscribers.
To give you more context for how fast
that growth is,
there are only three channels in the
world with more than 38 million
subscribers total and they're going to
gain that many subscribers in one year
according to growth trends.
At first glance,
this growth is completely baffling.
How is this possible?
At this point,
I'm just going to show you a few of
their videos to give you a flavor of the
kind of work that they do.
Hi.
I mean it's good,
but good content doesn't explain the
full picture.
There are tons of good music video
channels that aren't growing nearly this
fast.
So what else is going on here?
Well,
it's ironic.
The same thing that helped a cutie pie,
the youtube king get to where he is,
is now what is creating the new king of
Youtube.
It comes down to two factors.
These factors are geographic opportunity
and content ecosystems.
Let's start with geographic opportunity.
Five years ago,
Matt Pat made a video called how Pewdie
pie conquered youtube and in it he
argued Qd by had a unique advantage
based on where he was from.
Basically Pewdie Pie was able to draw
from a larger audience pulled in his
contemporaries,
which gave him the geographic
opportunity to get ahead.
Today the place to be if you want
geographic opportunity in the largest
audience is India.
India has always had a huge population,
but what held India back in the past was
having bad or no Internet connection.
But recently,
especially in the last decade,
this has been radically changing.
I don't want to bore you with too many
numbers,
but India has been coming online
rapidly.
To illustrate this,
there's a metric called Internet
penetration,
which just measures the percentage of
the country using the Internet.
Simple,
so to get a baseline here are the last
two decades in the US,
pretty stagnant and nearly everyone who
wants to be on the Internet is on the
Internet.
Now compare this with the last two
decades of Internet penetration in
India.
It's pretty staggering and as far as
absolute number of Internet users,
India is already well past the u s and
Europe and is only behind China in total
users,
and that's despite the fact that they
still have a long way to grow.
Having only reached 30% penetration
compared to the 80% of most modern
countries and leaving the geopolitical
implications of this aside for a moment
on youtube,
this means only one thing.
Holy Cow.
There are a lot of people looking for
content in India and more new users log
on every single day.
Let's do the math.
Exponential audience size,
hungry for content.
Who is the biggest channel in India?
Ready to give the people what they want?
T series.
They're soaking up all those new users
like a sponge,
but as if that wasn't enough.
Teasers has one other advantage that
seals the coffin for the borough.
Pewdie pie and just the rest of Youtube.
The India content ecosystem is young and
because of that competition is weaker in
America.
You may not realize it,
but we have a pretty mature content
ecosystem.
What I mean by that is while in the
beginning things were like the wild west
on Youtube,
the environment has grown with its
creators.
We've had people creating fulltime for a
while now.
We've had a large companies use youtube
for success.
We've even had a generation of creators
like me who grew up watching youtube.
Everyone's just had time to learn and
adapt.
This is a great thing for content.
It means there's more content than ever
and it's better than ever generally
speaking,
but it also means that competition for
your eyeballs is fiercer than ever.
In America and Europe today,
we have plenty of established channels
with professional budgets all competing
with one another.
This makes it hard to cut through and to
really stand out even for the biggest
and best channels.
This is also why people who start gaming
channels today have no chance of
becoming as big as purity clyde.
He did it when the John was new young,
an undefined,
don't get me wrong,
someone can still succeed on youtube,
but being first to market is always a
unique advantage.
If pewdie pie started today,
he'd be just one of a thousand similar
personalities all shouting for the same
breathing room and just contrast this
with India where new creators are just
starting to take advantage of the huge
opportunity over there.
Most of the audience and the creators
have only recently gotten Internet
access,
which means that India is youtube
content environment is at minimum
several years younger than most
developed countries.
This has created a unique moment for
professional operationally t series who
can afford to mass produce big budget
music videos to dominate the competition
and grab the market share before anyone
else gets there.
Now I know what you're thinking.
What about elephant in the room?
China,
because China,
you would think all these factors apply
equally to them as well.
Why aren't we seeing the t series of
China after all?
They have just as large of a population.
They're actually ahead of India in their
technological boom,
which means a larger potential audience
size.
What's holding them back?
Well,
China is the story of what might've been
except for a little something called the
Great Wall of China,
the great firewall it is.
You may have heard the Chinese
government sensors the Internet and
starting from the 2008 rights in Tibet.
One website they blocked is youtube.
So while China has their own youtube
called [inaudible],
which is a totally original title,
it's mostly a national brand.
So for now at least it looks like
India's friendliness towards
globalization will make it a stronger
competitor in worldwide entertainment.
While China's nationalist policies have
meant that national brands like you,
cool,
we'll succeed,
which is an interesting trade off.
China prevents their population from
engaging with global,
sometimes better products,
but in turn it gives their local
companies that normally would have been
out competed a long time ago.
The chance to grow into huge
corporations,
which can fight on the world stage for
influence,
but it's hard to tell how successful any
of their creators have been since
they're not playing on the same field as
any other country.
You really can't compare numbers.
If you don't go to the Olympics,
you can't win a medal no matter how many
people you have banging your drops.
So to summarize this video,
China's playing by themselves insulating
their internet platform so that it can
survive and grow while any is choosing
to leverage its huge population to
participate in the larger community and
with its technological boom only getting
started soon.
India will be a major player in the
youtube ecosystem.
It looks like Bollywood Music is here to
stay,
which is cool with me because have you
ever seen a bollywood movie?
Their action heroes have a level of bad
ass Uri that breaks the Badass meter and
turns into comedy,
which is hilariously amazing.
Yeah,
I'll just outro with the future of
Youtube here.
Yeah.
Hey,
are you tired of talking about land lock
nationalistic governments?
Is Bollywood dominating your favorite
creators is all this geo,
you tubical talk boring you to death.
Well you've come to the right place,
the coffee breaks,
shilling,
outro because we're done with that
international stuff and going back to
what matters my life in America because
I need your support after some
reflection,
based on the research I showed today,
I realized that I have essentially
started an anti popularity channel.
I started a year ago in an already
matured environment.
My style of video meets infrequent
uploads and because I came after Evan
Puschak somehow monopolize the video
essay,
everyone thinks I'm nerd writer too.
I need all the help I can get.
So if you've got money,
if you're swimming in the cheese,
that makes one of us.
So if you found this video valuable and
you want to take this relationship to
the next level,
consider supporting me on Patriot and
making that two of us that are rolling
in the dough one or $5 a month.
It's up to you.
Stop whenever you want.
All right.
Thanks for coming to the coffee breaks.
Shilling.
Outro.
We appreciate you being here.
A big thanks to my patrons.
Big thanks to the music producers linked
below and here and thanks to social
blade for making youtube analytics so
accessible.
Stay awesome.
Youtube.